- Cela fait des années
que l'on voit ces imag
de Vancouver. Et pourtant,
elles font toujours partie
"Tous les lundis, je reçois
un coupopopopour me dire
combien de personnes sont mortes
d'une surdose au cours de la
seilililililililililililililili"
"Impossible de trouver
cocococouvérois qui ne soit pas
touché personnellement par
ces statistiques", ajoute-t-il.
Pour faire face à la crise,
la ministre eteteteteteteteteteé
mentale tend cette exemption
à son hueueueue
britanno-colombienne.
À compter du mois de janvier
eticicicicicicicicicicicicicicie
pour un usage personnel
d'd'd'd'd'opioïdes, de cocaïne,
de méthamphétamine ou d'ecstasy
en Colombie-Britannique
et les substances ne seront
pas saisies. L'oesesesesest de
ne plus traiter les problèmes
de dépendance comme un crime,me.
BRIAN CONWAY, clinique maladie
infectieuses Vancouver
Et le détail de l'application ce
sera déterminant en termes
- Le Dr Brian Co
est directeur de la clinique
des maladies infectieuses
pour que la décriminalisationnnt
s'assurer que les consommateurs
soient pris en charge.
à la déstigmatisation,
d'une part, et l'implication
de ces gens-là dans
des systèmes de soins
ALEXANDRE BOULERICE, député, N
Rosemont - La Petite-Patrie, Qc
- Bravo pour les gens
- L'association canadienne
des chefs de polic
en vapeur de l'extension, mais
prévient que seule la mesure ne.
Ça prendra davantage des lits,
un meilleur accès au site
d'injection supervisée et
sécuritaire.
Rosemont - La Petite-Patrie, Qc
- Bravo pour les gens
de Colombie-Britannique,
mais il y a des morts
partout au pays.
Alexandre Boulerice,
le gouvernement doit aller
plus loin et plus vite.
Le NPD a déposé un projet pour
étendre la décriminalisati
- On vit depuis des années
une grave crise des opioïdes.Tos
sur le terrain nous disent
qu'on a absolument besoin de ça.
- Pas question pour la ministre.
Mais maintenant que C C C C C Ce
a créé le modèle, elle est
ouverte à accorder d'autres
mais Ottawa ne ferme déjà pas
la porte à accorder d'autres
exemptions, même si pour
l'instant, Santé Canada est
incapable de dire combien de
et combien de vies pourront être
sauvées grâce à cette mesure.
Ici Valérie Gamache,
Radio-Canada, Ottawa.